every weekend on book TV next Diane coil
discusses her book paradoxes of
prosperity why the new capitalism
benefits all in her talk she challenges
the view of World Bank and IMF
protesters that the new global economy
harms the poor this event from the World
Bank in Washington DC runs just over 50
minutes
yeah welcome this to all of you in the
world bank info shop here i have the
pleasure and honor to welcome and
introduce to you our guest our speaker
today diane coil she is a highly
acclaimed journalist and writer she has
for a number of years in the economics
editor of the English daily the
independent and she is as well and
acclaimed economist among other things
visiting research fellow at the London
School of Economics she has written
three books now if I'm right and the
most recent one is paradoxes of
prosperity which I understand is the
basis of what we were here today and I
am very glad to have her here I assume
we will have about half an hour or so a
lecture and then after that the flow is
open for discussions I was also asked to
as a housekeeping issue alert you to the
fact that after the event here we will
have a book signing session with some
refreshments over there in the real info
shop and without further ado I would
like Diane to speak to us thank you for
the introduction and I'm it's a real
pleasure to be here it's a slightly odd
experience for me in in two ways one is
that
in the past when i visited the World
Bank it's been as a journalist reporting
from the outside on the events taking
place here so it feels very odd to be
sitting on the platform instead of down
there taking notes secondly because
these days most often I find myself
sharing a platform with people who are
opponents of globalization and I end up
defending the World Bank and the IMF so
it's very odd not to be having in a
position having to do that today the
reason I end up in these kind of debates
which can get very bitter and personal
is because I've written a book paradoxes
of prosperity which is a sort of defense
of technology and globalization and it's
very hard to find apparently to find
people who will go out there and defend
globalization in any way at all so I've
been in great demand as a result of the
book to Joe engage in this debate I
started writing because the basic
paradox the puzzle for me was if you
believe that grows from technology
technology openness over the long run
transform living standards vastly for
the better which I do then why is it
that so many people feel really bad
about developments in the global economy
and about the technological change why
is there so much fear and anger about it
in a nutshell the answer is it's the
politics stupid and the book links the
new economy debate in the advanced
economies with the globalization debate
it suggests that it's the political
economy of technical change in the in
the advanced economies and that sheds a
lot of light on the positions people are
taking about globalization so I've got
about half an hour to speak I want to
concentrate on three areas one is what
does the argument that's being played
out on the streets including the streets
out here what does it seem to be about
what are the issues secondly are they
really the issues or is there something
else going on and why is it happening
now anyway and thirdly how can we move
forward constructively from the rather
entrenched positions that people have
taken especially if you believe as I do
that there is enormous potential in
globalization and technological
development
so let me start with the basic claims
made in the debate between the
campaigners and running dogs of
capitalism like myself the campaigns
between them they're a very diverse
Bunch but they make a lot of claims
mainly concerning poverty and inequality
and state of the environment so for
example they'll say globalization has
brought about the most obscene
inequality we've ever seen in history
and they've got favorite fact the
increase in the pay of American chief
executives compared to the average or
the extent of inequality in countries
like China or Brazil or the fact that
the US has pulled so far ahead of
sub-saharan Africa or the fact that
Microsoft could buy Costa Rica for lunch
and still have change they say that
globalization causes poverty that free
trade for example all it means is that
us maze gets dumped on African markets
with no reciprocal access they say that
trade is degrading the environment that
there's unnecessary movement of goods
that sir causing excessive use of energy
they make a cluster of claims about
multinationals that they're
unaccountable they're secretive they're
taking power at the expense of
governments so exploiting the poorest of
the poor through for example making them
by GM sees that carry the Terminator
gene or charging excessive prices for
medicines and so on all those the claims
about the financial markets they're
inherently destabilizing they speculate
deliberately against vulnerable
economies and our force for evil because
even George Soros says so there's a
conspiracy to keep poor countries in
debt because that gives the Western
powers to leave that over them and I
think even the most moderate people
believe that financial markets are a bad
thing and can't really understand why
they might be any trade offs or problems
with sending like a Tobin tax or capital
controls and in this do there's a real
mix of of truth and distortion and
downright error so in the book I spend
sometimes setting out a lot of the
evidence that there is actually some
good news on poverty reduction and on
life expectancy in some countries that
the big increase in inequality long
predates the modern era of globalization
and in fact may be stabilizing if you
look [ __ ] in a certain way
that openness and growth go hand in hand
in at least the minimal sense that no
country that's turned its back on the
outside world and trade has ever has
ever developed economically and I don't
think I really need to dwell on these
points because they'll be very familiar
to many of you but what's interesting to
me in presenting the complex evidence in
the details too many audiences is that
they're actually not interested at all
they don't care what the facts are and
they're not opened having their minds
changed by looking at the moon in detail
I think that what's going on is not for
the most part a technical debate about
the best ways to reduce poverty and
narrow the gap between rich and poor
countries which is what you might think
if you took at face value of the
arguments on both sides that technical
debate is important of course but it
just misses the point in terms of
politics which is it's not really about
globalization at all after all the
campaigners know that their protest is
negative they know they don't have not
hunted analytical framework for the
global economy and they understand the
irony in being very globalized and
cosmopolitan themselves so this takes me
on to my second question which is what
is really happening within this debate
and why is it happening now and this is
where the link was the issue of new
technology comes in I think the clue
lies in the fact that the globalization
debate has been pretty much internal to
the advantage economies it's about us
not about the world although it has to
be said the world might now at last be
getting a look in having intruded itself
so violently upon us in recent months so
what's been changing with us all kinds
of things there's social change there's
the geopolitical background there's the
demography but there's also the
technology and I think at this point I
need to say something about the new
economy if you remember if you remember
that phrase some people have always been
skeptical about whether there's a new
economy some people have skepticism
thrust upon them by the bursting of the
dot-com bubble
and again in the book I spent quite a
few chapters setting out the evidence on
whether or not there's been a
technologically related structural
change in the US and any other economies
and why that's actually separate from
the question of stock market valuations
personally I find the evidence that
there's a deep structural change that
something is going on not only
compelling but but blindingly obvious in
some ways but that's not so much because
of the US growth experience and the
growth accounting exercises and I think
they're always going to be disputed the
historical record suggests that lags
between the introduction of new
technologies and the impact on the
economy a long and variable and Paul
David's well-known electrification
example suggested a 50-year lag between
the first development of technologies
and widespread use of electricity in
homes and factories and an impact on
aggregate growth but the kind of growth
accounting exercises that have been so
popular for the US economy assumes it's
almost instantaneous they assume that
this year's investment in technology has
an impact on this year's productivity
growth and output growth there are lots
of other measurement issues as well
there's the issue about how do you
measure the output of services I mean
how do you measure the output of a nurse
it's not the number of patient she
manages to get through in a day how do
you measure the output of an Anderson
auditor and it looks like I might have
got that one very wrong there are also
questions about cyclical adjustment
what's the appropriate adjustment to
make the stage of the cycle when you
have such an unprecedented cycle to take
account of how do you capture in price
indices and the great changes in quality
and in the mix of goods that people are
buying should the capital stock include
intangible assets because growth
accounting doesn't include any and
there's a basic question about where the
ggp ever actually captures big
qualitative changes there's a very good
example of this I don't know if any of
you saw a TV series and that went out in
the head of the millennium celebrations
called the 1900 house it was made in
Britain it featured a family an ordinary
family who agreed to lead their lives
exactly the way there
Torian forebears had so there are no
modern amenities in their houses and
they couldn't buy any modern goods and
services and the thing that made the
woman break and head off down to the
supermarket was shampoo her grandmother
had not been able to wash her hair and
she found it transformed her life by
comparison with her grandma she couldn't
bear being that shampoo invention of
shampoo doesn't feature in GDP at all so
I think we shouldn't get hung up on the
precise growth figures they're
interesting of course but it's not the
be-all and end-all charles babbage the
forefather of the computer wrote a
letter wants to Alfred Tennyson the poet
he said sir in your otherwise
magnificent poem you include the line
every moment a man is born every moment
one dies a moment's reflection will show
you that this is nonsense because
otherwise the population would be static
I suggest that in the next edition of
your poem you change it to read every
moment a man dies every moment one and
one-sixteenth is born the precise number
is too long to fit on one line but I
think one and one sixteenth is
sufficiently accurate for poetry now I'm
persuaded by the poetry of what's
changing in the economy actually buy
things like the case studies that look
at businesses that have invested in the
technology and have reordered their
management and restructured their
production and made gains in
productivity of twenty-five or thirty
percent by other evidence the structural
breaks the macroeconomic relationships
like the fall in the stable inflation
unemployment rate in this country and in
Britain by the enormous surge in foreign
direct investment and trade in
components which indicate that
production really has been reorganized
globally and by things like the switch
in stock market valuations to reflect
intangible assets which investors have
now for 10 years concluded are important
if you concentrated on the growth and
the sorts of exercises actually show
steam and information technology running
neck and neck in terms of their
aggregate impact now I don't think many
of us would actually does this steam is
very unimportant but I think it'll be
quite a while before the cynics change
their minds
to me though the information technology
revolution is only about being able to
type faster in the way the trains were
only faster horses and electricity was
only about being able to read later into
the night you know actually we know that
electrification set in Shane a whole
series of responses new factories new
assembly lines universal basic education
to provide the workers for those
assembly lines the whole structure of
corporatism which in the end uh turley
transformed our societies and economies
I think as a profession we economist the
prone to being over reductive and
relatively few economists with the
honorable exception of some historians
have written much about the big picture
on capitalism and technology of course
one famous exception is Karl Marx who
said the history of all hitherto
existing society is the history of class
struggle and I wonder if it's not
possible that the great debate about
globalization is actually playing out
the conflict between different groups in
the economies of the North because after
all if you're talking about big losers
from globalization as opposed to not
very big gainers then those are groups
of northern workers it's the unskilled
or those with craft skills and declining
industries like steel it's the middle of
ranking professionals has been delayed
from corporations and it's probably all
kinds of workers in bureaucratic
institutions like the public sector that
may depend on the extent to which you
buy the argument that information
technology undermines the classic
bureaucratic command and control
pyramids and I think I do because
everywhere I look I see a crisis of
management in the public sector in
almost every country and in fact we've
got the same kind of Alliance now
between unions protecting jobs in
specific sectors and radical middle
class young people as characterize the
late 1960s it's the classic political
coalition and you can never stretch the
historical parallels too far but that
was also another era of multinational
bashing the defeat American because the
French then is now hated globalization
the most and the gnomes of Zurich being
blamed for financial crisis after
financial crisis so is easier to blame
somebody else
well of course steel workers and farmer
cuz they're against globalization and so
two of those who his parents may have
been downsized in the last recession or
who know that they're unlikely to
experience the lifelong job stability
and progression that their parents did
globalization has been bad for them and
Moore's probably going to be worth but
of course it's not effective for them to
campaign on self-interest alone
political messages have to have a
broader appeal and so they square the
circle by insisting that globalization
is bad for everybody including the pool
there's someone like me who canceled on
assess them well of course the world is
the terrible and unfair place and the
rich and powerful are rich and powerful
but actually there's some good news
around things are getting a little bit
better for the poor in some cases
multinationals are creating jobs and
boosting waitress in some countries and
then they say no that's not true the
facts show otherwise you say actually
the facts you know the facts I have them
here in my bag here's the world
development indicators if you look at
this table it shows you the portion
living on under a dollar a day has
fallen then they get very angry and this
is why the debate becomes bitter because
it's undermining the force for protest
his roots actually learn a different set
of issues and namely structural change
in the advanced economies so that it
smells my third question which is if
this is right how do we go forward in
this debate and I want to suggest that
we abolished the third world or the
developing economies there's a separate
category and development economics as a
separate part of the subject and talk
about the need generally to build a
wealthier and fairer society because I
think there are commonalities in the
analysis whether you're looking at poor
countries or or poor regions or poor
cities or poor parts of cities if you
compare the problems internal to the
north and the north-south problems
although of course they're very
different experiences poverty and
excessive inequality are problems
wherever they occur and I think that
analytically we're moving away from you
know another classic example of the
reductionism if economist which is
offering simple solutions to complex
problems and we have tools that allow
that to be done the analysis draws in
several ways on on spill
Earth's externalities and increasing
returns you can call it catch-22
economics it looks at problems like
investing in education individuals are
only going to invest in their own
education or their children's if they
expect a return out of it which means
they're going to be have to be better
paying jobs available but employers that
only going to create the better paying
jobs if they know that there's going to
be an appropriate workforce and edit
educated workforce there so the catch-22
who's going to start it there are spill
overs such that the social return to
investment in education vastly exceeds
the private return and it can create
virtuous and vicious circles of wealth
and an high skill or low skill and
poverty and this this kind of catch-22
applies not only to knowledge narrowly
defined as education but also to habits
and values and customs which is
important for thinking about things like
inner city clusters of poverty in in
northern cities why would you bother to
give up drugs and get out of bed in the
morning if nobody else around you does
that so there are no jobs available or
if you could train to try to commute out
for a job out of your own neighborhood
always assuming somebody bothers to run
a bus service to a place that nobody
commutes out of then your potential
employers are going to judge you by your
address and by your way of speaking and
your clothes and your deportment in all
those signals that you have picked up
from the people around you every day and
this is inherently geographical because
values and tests that knowledge depend
on face-to-face sex change it's not a
conventional market transaction the
success of the transaction the transfer
or its quality depends on proximity and
passing on values and all kinds of
knowledge is best on by personal contact
with people due respect and by following
the example set by those around you
because we're all conformists in the end
and this is a theme that has now been
developed in a separate literature on
inner-city deprivation but I think it
applies very widely the questions are
the same why does wealth creation
observe borders which are notional lines
on maps why is there no incentive to
invest in business or in education and
the answers all have the same form there
coordination problems whether a very big
externalities in my view this makes
migration a key issue now and this is of
course the great difference in the last
era of globalization in in the United
States now nine percent of the
population is foreign born in 1911 it
was fifteen percent and in the early
20th century the end the inward
migration rate to the US reached 102 per
thousand from some countries like
Ireland it was much higher as 142 per
thousand that was an extrordinary
movement of people and we haven't seen
anything like that the current public
policy debate tends to be about the
tension between the North wanting to
allow in skilled workers with a not very
hidden agenda of keeping a Titan of
control to prevent inward floods of
undesirables and the concern that this
is this is cherry picking it's a drain
on the finances and resources of poor
countries and their skill base but
invite in my view we in the North must
open our borders much more to people if
we're sincere about helping the
development process because it's the
only way to transfer knowledge and
experience analyse 16 ian has just
published a new paper documenting the
links running from immigrants in Silicon
Valley to the software industries in the
trip industries in India and Taiwan she
caused it brain circulation not brain
drain in many cases the people who
immigrated to Silicon Valley either go
back or they invest in businesses in
their home regions or at the very least
they offer a network of access to the US
market for people who are running
businesses in their home countries I
think the benefits also clearly two way
that we benefit not only from the skills
but also from the very diversity this
isn't exactly new John Stuart Mill input
principles of political economy wrote
the economic advantages of Commerce are
surpassed by those of its effects which
are intellectual and moral it's hardly
possible to overrate the value in the
present low state of human improvement
of placing human beings in contact with
persons disseminated themselves and with
modes of thought and action unlike those
with which they're familiar
there is no nation which does not need
to borrow from others so not new but I
think increasingly important because the
more economic activity shifts from
tangible manufactured and easily
monitored goods to intangible goods and
services depending on tacit knowledge
and values and reputation the more the
personal contact matters and I don't
think this is anything like the
conventional way of thinking about
migration in the public policy debate
but there's also more to the catch-22
economy on top of the human capital
spill overs there are the production
linkages between firms causing
geographic agglomeration of business the
supply chains in the customer base every
individual companies part of a network
which creates a strong externality for
each of them separately for any of them
to move would be extraordinarily costly
and stare for success breeds success in
business clusters and this plays into
the into the other kind of catch-22
they're mutually reinforcing because
increasingly in many businesses given
the way the current wave of technology
is shifting economic activity the tacit
knowledge is embedded in experienced
workers so you need you need the
workforce the experienced workforce even
more than ever before and those vicious
circles and virtuous circles become even
more deeply embedded in own services
from the lowest to the highest
technology it's very hard to distinguish
quality from quantity a lot of the work
is difficult to monitor and it depends
on personal trust between customer and
company and between employer and
employee and this is increasingly true
in manufacturing as well where the value
in the process is more and more and
things like the design the research the
marketing then the mechanical processing
of materials so as an employer in
manufacturing industry if one of your
designers says they have to take a very
long lunch and then go to the art
gallery you just have to trust that is
going to pay off in terms of their work
all of this means I think that it's just
not very easy to copy success anymore
it's hard to imitate so there's a sense
in which the technological shifts are
moving the goalposts quite dramatically
and you have to ask whether this means
the language is ever going to be able to
catch up I think the Avalanche metaphor
is very appropriate for economic growth
you've got to jump up and down very
vigorously in the right place to set off
the avalanche and more than that it
helps this some other people are jumping
up and down as well you've got to have
the right shape of the mountainside
you've got to have had the right kind of
snow and you've got to have the right
weather conditions so it's hard but my
goodness when it starts its dramatic and
you can get a very very dramatic change
very quickly it's hard to coordinate
policies in the right way at the right
time if ever we thought they were
panaceas surely we know that's not true
now but the results if you get it right
can be extraordinary and we have
examples a few we have the examples of
countries in the European periphery like
Ireland and Spain and Portugal and we
have the examples of countries like
South Korea in East Asia they were
transformed within a generation which is
an amazing speed so I think I ended up
being optimistic for two reasons
essentially one is just to be
provocative and contrarian because it's
so fashionable to be gloomy but the
other is the increasing importance of
this tacit knowledge and experience and
human creativity compared to the past
when the key resources were very very
unfairly distributed and tightly
controlled the key resources now are in
the hands of a much wider group of
people than in the past and I think
that's basically good news but I
wouldn't say it's easy thanks very much
and I think we now have some time for
comments and questions
and who's going to be brave enough to
start
I have to tell you this is a lot lot
quieter than my usual Hortense's he
would be challenging everything I've
said about any upbeat any upbeat news
I'll tell some of the good questions
well one of the questions that I'm not
sure I know the answer to so I will
throw this open for discussion is
whether technology helps developing
countries directly is there any is there
any hope in the technologies themselves
and I think on balance I there is
because although in the one hand I've
described this process that's making
moving the goalposts and making it
harder to imitate a success in the way
that for example Japan did in the 60s
there are several other factors one is
that I think some of the new
technologies directly hold great promise
that the GM foods if therefore allowed
to be developed and and medical by
biotechnology developments in themselves
holder greatly to promise and we're
working towards developing institutions
that will diffuse those more widely than
some technologies have been diffused in
the past another thing is the
possibility of leapfrogging and I guess
the best example is mobile phones in
Africa where there are now as many
Mobile's as fixed lines and the third
thing is actually foreign direct
investment because that has been
directly made possible by information
technology it wasn't possible for a
company to operate globally in this way
with that information technology and
communications technologies and I think
I think foreign direct investment is
actually one of the best channels for
planting industries and planting
experience and technology transfer in
developing countries but I'd be very
interested to hear what other people
here think about them
do you think that some of the pressure
to broaden
commercial drive for things beyond the
sort of dollar or palm bottom line and
include aspects such as the
environmental impact protection to the
GM foodies on this is making progress
must be socially responsible as we go
from I think the fact there are so many
our appreciation that there are so many
externalities is going to call into
question the market market mechanism in
some ways because we know perfectly well
that Marcus don't don't respond
appropriately when there are large
externalities I'm not sure to what
extent individual corporations are able
to take it on themselves obviously
there's a very strong movement towards
corporate social responsibility which is
a good thing and leading-edge leading
edge companies are behaving much better
than in the past they're taking account
of the communities in which they operate
in and where they didn't use to I think
that's all very all very healthy but if
you talk to executives about it they are
also uneasy because they think they are
being asked to do society's work
politicians work for them so for example
on the question about what you have to
do to be incorporated in an ethical
investment index like the footsie for
good or the American equivalent they're
very uneasy about having to respond to
questionnaires that are sent out by
nongovernmental organizations that they
feel arbitrary they would like to see
the securities and exchange commission
or other government authorities set out
the parameters and tell them they think
this is politician strawberry they
should be given some some guidance they
can't step in and do the politicians job
for them
two things that you talked about what is
the technology and how
the holy plate
from isn't a spare
both countries
the other point is
oh these two
played out in a situation
the lesson the transfer was the
environment right in front
they come on execution today
report
investment in technology
very important
has filed bankers how display
the encouraging thing about the years
since then the asian financial crisis i
suppose is how little foreign direct
investment has has fallen in fact it
hasn't fallen has been stable and
started to increase slightly again so
the forces for companies to continue
that process are clearly still operating
and of course recessions will affect
investment plans and personally I'm not
that gloomy about about prospects for
the American economy and therefore the
rest of the world economy but the other
consideration is those companies that
have already made the investments not
only in the technology but also in the
kinds of structures they need to use it
effectively have seen such big
productivity gains and so when the
economy does pick up again that means
their competitors are eventually going
to have to follow because otherwise
they'll go out of business in the long
run it can take a very long time but
once some people start capturing those
sorts of games which are huge they are
twenty-five percent or so than others
than others do follow but your other
point I think is a very difficult one
because as you know as you say does
foreign direct investment goes to a
relatively narrow range of countries and
no company is going to want to invest a
lot of money put a lot at risk in a
country that has a lot of violence or
political instability if I knew how to
bring about world peace I would gladly
tell you it's about changing the
behavior of a lot of individuals at the
same time and that's one of the hardest
problems we face as human beings I don't
know how to do
do you have comments or insights you
might have about the role of the World
Bank specifically and also the press the
role of the press is playing in the
globalization debate how it's being
characterized how it's being reported
I'm not a great expert on the internal
workings of the bank it's six months
since I was a journalist a daily
journalist it does seem to me that what
the bank is geared up to do is hand out
money and I'm rather skeptical about the
benefits of handing out more money I
have to say and also about making any
generalizations about what's appropriate
and I do think it's time to stop trying
to come up with with big solutions big
easy solutions but under looking much
greater detail at individual situations
the press I think that's a very
difficult and interesting issue one of
the reasons I decided to quit being a
journalist and go back to my roots as an
economist was I got fed up of editors
only being interested in riots when they
wanted something about globalization and
it was almost impossible to get them
interested in anything less exciting and
photogenic and this is the reason why so
many NGOs have gone along with the
violence of course because they will
openly admit that it's brought them
publicity that they wouldn't have got in
decades otherwise and they find it very
frustrating that the sensible campaigns
like Jubilee 2000 that had a handle on
the technical issues obviously got a
very strong point of view but they were
nonviolent and determined and put a lot
of work into it we're very frustrated by
the fact that the process got hijacked
by violent violent minority
I'm not sure I know what the answer to
that is because it's obviously an
intellectual fashion amongst many people
in the press to think the globalization
is bad and to think that that the
riences what's interesting about it and
I don't know whether this is because of
the pressure of constant 24-hour news in
the competition between outlets and so
there's a sort of an arms race to have
the most outrageous and exciting news I
don't really know what the source of the
problem is and if I'd known a solution
to it I would actually stay two
journalists myself very difficult issue
is pushing where you said
basic to
ostriches
alright
articulate my mother
defense of Google
in the
I'm possibly
the five useless people globally
when it is broken foot
asian is also good
alpèasak
because we might have situations for
example information technology
developing ponies
just logically fastest longer
our without the random transfer of the
culture of topology
there's also the whole cultural answer
to that this fear of him over 15 years
what
yes I know there's all that issue
we should also get very
possibly harmful to driver all this
boys are doing
by the NGOs who does that belong to
I think you're right I don't want to
downplay any of those difficulties at
all and of course any kind of any kind
of structural economic transformation is
bound to be an upheaval for some groups
people absolutely everywhere and the
process of modernization and gross has
always been fraught with difficulties
and and and problems and uncertainty and
we know that people don't like don't
like the uncertainty and the example of
right back in the beginning of the
Luddite riot shows that you know that
shows the truth of that so I absolutely
agree with you I end up sounding talking
about it the way I do because I'm so
often the only person saying any
anything positive about globalization
but I certainly don't mean to downplay
the negative aspects of it either I
don't want to sound triumphalist about
it at all
yes
yeah um I've instituted to hear you
speak a little more about your
conclusion that the politics of
criticism of globalization is internal
to the north in my experience that think
there's a very active and engaged
community of critics in the global south
as well and part of one of the main
pillars of the NGOs and civil society in
the north is assisting those in the
South who are making criticisms either
about the architecture of globalism
generally or about specific projects
that the world bank may be financing um
to have a voice in the debate which
which they often otherwise would not
have so um I'd like to hear you talk
about what you see is the the politics
of globalization in the south and what
and why you emphasize more well firstly
obviously there are lots of different
kinds of NGOs and in a sense it's a
mistake to generalize about them because
they have different kinds of experience
in different agendas what I was meaning
to say was I thought that the public
policy debate and the reason politicians
in the advanced economies are responding
is because it does affect interest
groups of voters and it's kind of
classic interest group interest group
politics I don't really believe it would
be on the on the political agenda in the
way it is if it weren't for that you
know if it were only about some very
committed people aware of what was
happening in the south and bringing that
to the attention of people in their own
in their own countries and trying to
change policy I don't think it would
have had the kind of impact it has and I
don't think you'd see the g7 leaders so
concerned about it and all the all the
grandstanding what's going on
does answer your question or do you want
to come back to me oh cuz you're looking
skeptical well I think that I mean it's
somehow something it's sort of hard to
respond without reading the book but I
think that you may be falling ezel to
meet but you may be falling into the
same trap that you pointed out the media
falls into in focusing on the extremes
rather than on the full range of global
criticism but um while it may be true
that the attention of decision makers in
the g7 might not have been grabbed
without this sort of interest group
politics I think it's still true that
there is a large community of critics in
the south that would be voicing their
criticisms perhaps a different way even
if northern interest groups weren't
engaged and I'm wondering how you see
that feeding into the organization
process well I've got the greatest
separation for people who do take the
issues and the evidence very seriously
and are working on campaigns to try and
make a difference and I think well one
good thing to have emerged from the past
few years is that there's an opportunity
for whatever reason this is now on the
political agenda and there are
opportunities to make a difference in a
way that I can't remember before in my
adult life actually so in a sense that's
quite a hopeful time but i think it is
essential that people in the campaign's
really do pay attention to the evidence
and as i started out by saying my
experience has been over and over again
that they are not interested in the
evidence honor
so how do you
well I would argue by trying to change
the terms of the debate and this is why
I was making an argument for not not
saying development in poor countries is
a separate sort of issue and that the
issues are about fairness generally and
unprofessional I just think as a tactic
that will make it easier to turn it into
a much more focused debate on what he's
going to work and what's going to make
what's going to make a difference to the
lives of poor people just as a way of
getting the debate out of the current
tram lines and maybe if that will happen
anyway maybe the you know offical media
are going to get bored with another riot
especially if they're turning into damp
and damper scribbs as last weekend's and
New York did so maybe that maybe that
would happen anyway but I think you need
some kind of different perspective on
the problems to try and get people
thinking about it in different ways and
not reach for the same old facts that
they have in their minds whether they're
true or not
yeah hungry interested in here you use
about the relationship or the
interactions between this globalization
and the fight against terrorism and
perhaps the wrong that the World Bank
Group should play in this all global
mission I'm no expert on terrorism I
think the link is obvious it's it's the
it's the failed States because you have
to ask yourself if they weren't in that
situation would they you know would they
be able to exist as terrorists Punderson
states as opposed to state-sponsored
terrorism um but I don't I don't
actually feel comfortable talking about
how to fight how to fight terrorism much
happy to talk about how to tackle how to
tackle failed States and I think that's
very difficult because that's you know
there's an old joke that people tell in
Ireland or if you're going there you
don't want to start from here you don't
really want to start from where they are
if you're trying to become a developed
and peaceful economy to you and to go
back to an earlier question I think it
is really about thinking how you might
change a lot of people's behavior at the
same time it's the kind of coordination
problem and how do you create the
incentives that a lot of people to start
behaving differently and to believe that
if they invest education if they set up
a business then the appropriate rewards
are going to be there and that's
obviously something in which the World
Bank has a really important role to play
because governments are not really in a
position to do it for themselves and
there's also the question of technical
know-how in answering that kind of
problem
so if the World Bank focuses on that and
can make a difference I think that would
be the most the most fantastic
achievement much better than handing out
more loans and every time I say that
people laugh is obviously the kind of
internal debate yes I'm just following
up on that the whole relation between
good governance developments the
localization also linked with economic
growth we do have certain countries for
example in Africa I can and Ghana that
have undertaken economic reforms
all the other peoples of Canada there is
a government that especially in good
governance inflation is down other
indexes are pointing the right word but
there is no inflow what options are left
to countries like this
there's clearly a role for the World
Bank in trying to encourage possibly
even offer guarantees for the inflows in
those sorts of situations there are also
some obvious some obvious things that we
need to do we need to open our markets
in agriculture and textiles in a way
that we haven't done in the past
apparently the European Union spent so
much on agricultural subsidies that we
could fly our 45 million cars one and a
half times around the world first class
for the money this the scandal it's
shocking and we really we really need to
do something about it but as you don't
need me to tell you the politics of that
are extraordinarily difficult
ok I'm just going to comment below
the bottom line or the
the social function field vectors
yes we thank you son
yes absolutely agree and this the
dichotomy between private sector and
public sector is really unhelpful
because there's no such thing as a
market in the abstract the framework for
Marcus has always set by governments and
policies and the legal framework and so
on so I absolutely agree with that
I think we can prob be sorry you can't
start now you might stop everyone one
thing
colocalization and
case or
too many people in
actually sir
too fast to put a twist on
they're so it seems it's a wave of
nomination that's coming
so it's kind of rebellion
stopping this which they don't know what
this white thing
what was so the environment is not dead
probably we need to prepare a very first
and state back
under how easy it is to slow down you
see because a lot of it I wouldn't I
wouldn't say it's inevitable or an extra
one anyway but controlling the process
is is extraordinarily difficult and you
could say obvious things like no need to
open up the capital markets very quickly
this little war but there's a internet
available
love is not selling to lose your school
or not people entirely safe from
problems so it just that's a
and that's that's what I
but I saw happen
the country okay I would agree but I
think it's rate I think it's very hard
to control because basically we don't
understand the process is very well you
know I think economist thought to be a
lot more modest than we have tended to
be about what is that causes growth and
why these why these things happen in the
way that they do you know we have some
insights but actually we don't
understand them well enough to control
them very carefully so I would agree
with you but with that with that caveat
we found it without fertilization
the randomization
the emblem of people in class issues
between
gifts we just build that
beside it because
it's a culture except it's not economic
class
to see don't say somebody who grew up in
nineteen sixties and seventies Britain
was if the first food was terrible when
McDonald's came we were all
fantastically excited and thought it was
incredibly sophisticated and wonderful
food so I've always slightly still
slightly taken aback when people choose
the patent offices the emblem of all
what's bad about globalization because
we loved it but i think i'm very happy
to carry on and talking to people in
less formal circumstances let me thank
you very much for being here and for the
wonderful presentation and we could
carry on the rest of the conversation in
the info shop where they an will will do
some book signing and the reception
therefore for everybody some food and
some drinks so thank you very much
Diane Coyle was economics editor for the
independent from nineteen ninety three
to two thousand one she's currently a
visiting fellow at the London School of
Economics paradoxes of prosperity why
the new capitalism benefits all is
published by tix array you can visit
etex ericom to get more information